[Music]
hi everyone thank you for coming and
today we're going to talk about machine
learning ap is by example I'm going to
teach you how you can access pre-trained
machine learning models with a single
API call my name is Sarah Robinson I'm a
developer advocate on the Google cloud
platform team which basically means I
get to help build demos give talks about
them and bring product feedback back to
the engineering teams you can find me on
twitter at s robb tweets and i live in
new york so before i get started let's
talk about what machine learning is at a
high level but a high level machine
learning is teaching computers to
recognize patterns in the same way that
our brains do so it's really easy for a
child to recognize the difference
between a picture of a cat and a dog but
it's much more difficult to teach
computers to do the same thing right so
we could write rules to look for
specific things but we can almost always
find a condition that's going to break
those rules so instead we want to do is
write code that finds these rules for us
and improves over time through examples
and experience here we have a neural
network that's identifying a picture as
either a picture of a cat or a dog and
we can think of the input to this
network as pixels in the image and then
each neuron is looking for a specific
identifying feature maybe it's the shape
of the ear or the hair and then the
output is a prediction in this case that
is a dog let's take a step back from
this for a moment and let's try some
human powered image detection if we were
to do this on our own we'll take this
picture of an apple and an orange and
let's say we were going to start writing
an algorithm that would identify the
difference between these two what are
some features that you might look for
you can shout it out color I heard I
heard a bunch of color so cup shape the
texture lots of good ones the colors a
good one but then what would happen we
had black and white images and we might
have to start all over again so now in
that case we could look for a stem
texture would be good then what happens
if we add a third fruit if we add a
mango we have to start all over again as
well but these pictures are all pretty
similar right so what would happen if we
had pictures of two things that were
very
different this should be really easy
right a dog and a mop have pretty much
nothing in common from these pictures
that I can see but it's actually a
little tricky so what we have here is
pictures of sheep dogs and mops and it's
actually kind of hard to tell the
difference right if we were going to
write code that identified these two it
would be pretty tricky to do and then
what happens if we have photos of
everything we don't want to write
specific rules to identify each little
thing that we're trying to look for and
in addition to photos we could have many
other types of unstructured data we
could have video audio text lots of
different types of data we'd be dealing
with and really we want some tools to
help us make sense of all this
unstructured data and Google cloud
platform has several products to help
you benefit from machine learning on the
left-hand side here you can use your own
data to build and train your own machine
learning models so we have tensorflow
and cloud machine learning engine for
you to do that and on the right hand
side this is where I'm going to focus
today this is what I like to call
friendly machine learning these are
machine learning api's that give you
access to a pre trained machine learning
model with one single rough API request
if you make a request you send you send
it some data you get some data back from
this pre trained model and you don't
have to worry about building and
training your own model or anything
that's going on under the hood we're
going to give you an introduction to
each of these five AP is I'm going to
start with vision and I'm going to end
with video intelligence which is our
newest API you may have seen in the
keynote yesterday so let's get started
with vision the vision API lets you do
complex image detection with a simple
rest request and I'm going to start each
section by talking about a customer or
customers that are using each API so for
the vision API the first example on the
left is Disney used the vision API for a
game to promote the movie Pete's dragon
and the way the game works is that users
were given a quest so they had a clue
and they had to they had to take a
picture of that word maybe couch
computer everyday objects and if they
took the picture correctly they would
superimpose an image
of the dragon on that object so the
problem was they needed a way to verify
that the user took a picture of the
correct objects that they were prompted
for and the vision API was the perfect
fit to do that they use the label
detection feature which basically tells
you what is this a picture of and they
were able to verify images in the game
that way realtor.com uses the vision API
for their mobile application so it's a
real estate listing service and people
can go around as they're looking for
houses and take pictures of a for sale
sign and they use the vision API is OCR
optical character recognition to read
the text in the image and then pull up
the relevant listing for that house
those are two examples of the vision API
in production let's talk a little bit
more about the specific features of the
vision API so as I mentioned we have
label detection kind of a core feature
which tells you you send an image in
this case it's a cheetah and it'll tell
you what this is a picture of give you a
bunch of different labels back face
detection will identify faces in an
image it'll tell you where those faces
are in the image and they'll even tell
you if they're happy sad surprised or
angry OCR is what I mentioned with
realtor.com use case this can identify
text and image it will tell you where
the text is what the text says and what
language is in explicit content
detection will tell you is this image
appropriate or not really useful if
you've got a site with a lot of
user-generated content and you don't
want to manually filter images you can
use this API method to do that really
easily landmark detection will tell you
is this a common landmark if so what is
the latitude and longitude and then logo
detection pretty self-explanatory will
identify logos in an image so a quick
look at some of the JSON response you
might get back for these different
features this is face detection is
actually a selfie that I took with two
teammates on a trip to Jordan last year
and the response you're looking at in
the slide is on my face a little return
an object for each face you find in the
image and we can see it says head we're
likelihood very unlikely which is true
I'm not wearing a hat but for both of my
teammates it did return
had where likelihood very likely and
then we can see it's highlighted below
it says joy likelihood is very likely
which is true I am smiling in the
picture the next feature I want to show
you the response for is landmark
detection so we have a picture here of
what looks like the Eiffel Tower it's
actually the Paris Hotel and Casino in
Las Vegas I wanted to see if the vision
API was fooled and it was not correctly
identified this as the Paris Hotel and
Casino you can see that mi D in the JSON
response that's an ID that maps to
Google's knowledge graph API which will
just give you a little more data about
the entity and it also tells us the
latitude and longitude of where this
Paris Hotel and Casino is in addition to
these features we launched some new
features this week which you may have
heard about in yesterday's keynote I'm
going to quickly talk about what they
are and then I'll show you some examples
the first one is crop hints which will
give you suggested crop dimensions for
your photos web annotations I'm super
excited about this one this will give
you some granular data on entities web
entities that are found in your image
it'll also tell you all the other pages
where the image exists on the internet
so if you need to do copyright detection
it'll give you the URL of the image and
a URL where of the page where the image
is and then finally we announce document
text annotations so in addition to the
OCR we had before this is improved OCR
for large blocks of text if you have an
image of a receipt or something with a
lot of text it'll give you very granular
data on the paragraphs and the words and
the symbols in that text some examples
of the new features I want to highlight
web annotations so here we have a
picture of a car it's in a museum I'm
actually big Harry Potter fan so this is
a car from one of the Harry Potter
movies and I wanted to see what the
vision API was able to find from the web
entities in this image so it was able to
identify it correctly as a Ford Anglia
which is correct this from the second
Harry Potter movie when they tried to
fly a car to school
second entity returned is art Science
Museum and this is a museum in Singapore
where this car is on display and is
finally able to tell me that this car is
from Harry Potter which is a literary
series so lots of great metadata you can
get back from web annotations even more
data that it returns it tells you the
full matching image URLs where else does
this image exists on the Internet
partial matching images and then finally
all the pages that point to this image
it's really useful information you get
back with web annotations and you can
try this in the browser with your own
images before writing any code just go
to cloud.google.com slash vision you can
upload your images play around see all
the responses you get back from the
different features and you can actually
do this with all of the api's that i'm
going to talk about today there's a way
to try them in the browser and in case
you were wondering how the vision API
did with the sheepdogs and mops so this
is the response it got from that picture
on the right so it's 99% sure it's a dog
it actually even is able to identify the
breed of the dog Komondor and maybe
saying that wrong and the mop
successfully identified this as a broom
or a tool and skipping ahead it did
pretty well overall the top row the
third one it didn't identify it as a dog
it just said fur so I don't know if
that's a hit or miss and then the third
mop it said textile so it didn't quite
get that it was a mop or a broom but
overall vision API did perform pretty
well on these tricky images that are
even hard for us to decipher what they
are exactly that was the vision API I'm
showing you how you can get a lot of
data on your images with a pre trained
machine learning model next I want to
talk about audio data and the speech API
essentially exposes the functionality of
okay Google to developers lets you do
speech to text transcription in over 80
languages one app it's using the speech
API is called a czar and they have
connected 15 million matches an app to
find friends and chat and they use the
speech API for all of
messages that involve audio snippets and
they're also using this in combination
with the cloud translation API which I'm
going to talk about later on so there's
a lot of potential use cases where you
could combine different machine learning
api's together so in cases where the
matches don't speak the same language
they'll use a speech API to transcribe
the audio and then the translation
translation API to translate that text
the best way to experience the speech
API is with a demo before I get into it
I want to explain a bit how it works so
we're going to make a recording I wrote
a bash script we're going to use socks
to do that it's a command-line utility
for audio so what we'll do is we'll
record our audio we'll create an API
request in a JSON file we'll send it to
the speech API and then we'll see the
JSON response so if we could go ahead
and switch to the demo okay I'm gonna
make this font a little bigger so I'm
going to call my file ass bash request
SH and it says press ENTER when you're
ready to record it's going to ask me to
record a 5 second audio file so here we
go I built a cloud speech API demo using
socks okay so this is the JSON request
file that it just created we need to
tell the speech API the encoding type in
this case we're using FLAC encoding the
sample rate in Hertz the language code
is optional if you leave it out it will
default to English otherwise you need to
tell it what language your audio is in
and then the speech context I'm going to
talk about that in a little bit so I'm
going to call the speech API it's making
a curl request and let's see how it did
okay so it did pretty good that I built
a cloud speech API demo using socks but
you'll notice it got the wrong socks
because socks is a proper noun
it was 89 percent confident that it got
this correct that even is able to get
API as an acronym so I mentioned this
speech context parameter before and what
this actually lets you do is let's say
you have a proper noun or a word that
you're expecting your application that's
unique that you wouldn't expect the API
to recognize normally
you can actually pass it as a parameter
and it'll look out for that word so I'm
going to hop on over to sublime and I'm
going to add socks as a phrase to look
out for and let's see if it's able to
identify it I'm going to say the same
thing again I'm going to record I built
a cloud speech API demo using socks and
we can see it's now got that phrase in
there and we will call the speech API
and it was able to get it correctly
using the phrases parameter which is
pretty cool
just one ruff API requests and we are
easily transcribing an audio file even
with a unique entity and you can also
pass the API audio files in over 80
different languages you just need to
tell it again the language code that
you'd like it to transcribe so that is
the speech API and you can hop back to
the slides so we just transcribed our
audio we have text so what happens if
you want to do more analysis on that
text and that is where the natural
language API comes into play lets you
extract entities sentiment and syntax
from text a company that's using the
natural language API is called whoo
trick and they are a customer feedback
platform to help businesses improve
their customer service and they do this
by collecting millions of survey
responses each week a little more detail
on how it works is if you look at that
box in the top right so a customer would
place this on different pages throughout
their app maybe if you're a developer
you would see it on the documentation
page and it would say ask you to rate
your experience on that page from 0 to
10 which is what we call the Net
Promoter Score NPS so they gather that
score and then they give you some open
feedback to expand on what you thought
of the experience so as you can imagine
it's pretty easy for them to average out
the net promoter score among tons of
different responses but what's much more
difficult it's looking at that
open-ended feedback that's where they
use the natural language API make sure
we made use of all three methods
in the natural language API so they use
intimate analysis to calibrate the
numbers score that users gave with their
feedback to see if it aligned and then
they use the entity and syntax
annotation to figure out what the
subject was of the feedback and then
route it accordingly so maybe somebody
was unhappy about pricing then they
could route that feedback to the
necessary person and respond pretty fast
so using the natural language API they
were able to route and respond to
feedback in near real-time rather than
having someone need to read each
response classify it and then route it
so let's look at each of the methods of
the natural language API in a bit more
detail as I mentioned a big Harry Potter
fan so I took this sentence from JK
Rowling's Wikipedia page and let's see
what happens if we send this to the
entity extraction endpoint so it's able
to pull these five entities from the
sentence and the JSON we get back looks
like this so it's interesting here is JK
Rowling's name is written in three
different ways
Robert Galbraith is actually a pen name
she used for a later book series and
it's able to point all of these to the
same entity so if you had things like
San Francisco and SF it would point
those to the same entity so that you
could count the different ways of
mentioning the same thing as the same
entity so we can say it finds your name
Joanne Jo Rowling it tells you what type
of entity it is a person and then if
entity has metadata it'll give you more
metadata about it so here we get an EM
ID which maps to JK Rowling's knowledge
graph entry and then we get the
Wikipedia URL to the page about her the
JSON response looks similar for the
other entities we found British it maps
it to a location and then notice it
connects it to the United Kingdom
Wikipedia URL so if it had instead said
UK or United Kingdom it would point it
to the same page and then for Harry
Potter we also get person and we get the
Wikipedia page for that entity as well
so that's entity extraction that's one
method you could use in the natural
language API
the next one is sentiment analysis so
this is a review you might see it says
the food was excellent I would
definitely go back and we get two things
here we get a score value which will
tell us is the sentiment positive or
negative it's a value ranging from
negative one to one so we can see here
it's almost completely positive and then
magnitude will tell you how strong is
the sentiment regardless of being
positive or negative this is this can
range from 0 to infinity and it's based
on the length of the text so since this
is a pretty short block of text the
value is pretty low and then finally you
can analyze syntax so this method is a
bit more complex gets into the
linguistic details of a piece of text it
returns a bunch of different data here
this visualization is actually created
from the in browser demo so if you want
to try it out in the browser you can
create a similar visualization with your
own text and what it returns is on that
top row those green arrows that's what
we call a dependency parse tree and that
will tell us how each of the words in
the sentence relate to each other which
words they depend on in the second row
we see the orange row that's the parse
label which tells us the role of each
word in the sentence so we can see that
helps the sentences the natural language
API helps us understand text helps is
the root verb class is the nominal
subjects we can see the role of all the
other words in the sentence as well that
third row where we only have one word is
ulema we can see here it says help and
what that is is a canonical form of the
word so the canonical form of helps is
help so this way if you if you're trying
to count how many times the specific
word occurs it won't count helps and
help us to different words it'll
consolidate them into one word and then
in red we have the part of speech well
there's a noun verb adjective or
punctuation and then in blue we have
some additional morphology details on
the word there's more of these returned
for Spanish and Japanese which are the
other two languages that the API
currently supports
so the syntax annotation feature might
be a little harder to grasp when you
might use this in an application so I
wanted to show you a demo specifically
focused on that feature and for this
demo over the course of the past few
days I think the there we go
mic is back I've been using the Twitter
streaming API to stream tweet Google
necks
so I've streamed tweets at the hashtag
Google next 17 and a couple other search
terms or the node service that's running
on compute engine and I'm streaming
those tweets the streaming API gathers
just a subset of those tweets not all
the tweets without hashtags and I'm
sending the text of the tweet to the
natural language API and then I'm
storing the response in bigquery it
queries our big data analytics warehouse
tool lets you do analytics on really
large data sets I'm storing it in
bigquery and then from there I can
gather some data on the parts of speech
in the sentence so I can find for
example like most common adjectives that
people are using to tweet about Google
necks so if we could go to the demo cool
so this is the bigquery web UI which
lets you run queries directly in the
browser so here I just did a limit 10 to
show you what the table looks like I
think I've got about 6 to 7 thousand
tweets in here so far so here I'm
collecting ID of the tweets the text the
created at how many followers user has
what hashtags it finds that's returned
from the Twitter API and then I've got
this giant JSON string of the response
from the natural language API you're
probably wondering how am I going to
write a sequel query to parse that well
bigquery has a feature called
user-defined functions which lets you
write custom JavaScript functions but
you can run on rows in your table so
over here I've got a query that's going
to run on every tweet in this table and
my JavaScript function is right here and
what it's going to do is it's going to
count all the adjectives and then return
that in my output table so if I run this
query here it's running this custom
JavaScript function on all the tweets in
my table so I think is about 6,000 right
now it ran pretty fast and I'm not using
cache results
so let's take a look we've got four oh
five uses of the word more new great
good late awesome see some more here so
that's one example of a use case for the
syntax annotation feature of the natural
language API you can go back to the
slides
natural language API lets you do
analysis on text one other thing that
you might want to do with text is
translate it you likely have users of
your application all over the world be
useful to translate it into their host
language and then translation API
exposes the functionality of Google
Translate to developers and lets you
translate text in a hundred plus
languages and for a second let's talk
about Google Translate I'm a big fan of
Google Translate so anyone here used it
before looks like a lot of people I use
it when I travel all the time so a
couple months ago I was on the trip to
Japan I was at a restaurant where nobody
spoke English and I really wanted to
order octopus to typed it into Google
Translate turns out the word for that is
taco which confused me a little bit
didn't want to order an octopus taco all
that maybe that maybe that would be good
so I just showed the person at the
restaurant my Google Translate app
successfully got my octopus that's a
picture of it right there but likely you
want to do more than translate the word
for octopus and that's why we have the
translation API which lets you translate
text in your application in many
different languages and airbnb is an
example of a company that's using the
translation API and what you might not
know is that 60% of Airbnb bookings
connect people that are using the app in
different languages because people use
Airbnb a lot especially when they travel
internationally and so for all of those
connections they're using the translate
API to translate not only listings but
also reviews and conversations into the
person's host language and they found
that this significantly improves a guest
likelihood to book if it's translated
into their host language that's one
example of someone using the translation
API it's pretty self-explanatory but I
want to show you a code snippet of how
easy it is to call the API this is some
Python code
that's making a request to the
translation API and you can see here we
just create a translate client and then
we pass it the phrase we'd like to
translate the target language it will
detect the original language for us and
then we can print the result and one
thing we've added to the translation API
recently is neural machine translation
and this greatly improves the underlying
translation model and basically the way
it works is with first generation
translation which is what we had before
it was translating each word in a
sentence separately so let's say you had
a dictionary and you were looking up
word for word
each sentence in the dictionary and
translating it without understanding the
context around that word that works
pretty well but what neural machine
translation does is it actually looks at
the surrounding words and it's able to
understand the context of the sense the
word in a sense and it's able to produce
much higher quality translations there's
a great New York Times article with a
lot more details on how that model works
you can find it at that bitly link there
if anyone's to take a picture I'll leave
it up for a second and just to show you
some of the improvements that neural
machine translation brings there's a lot
of text I know but what I did is I took
a paragraph from the Spanish version of
Harry Potter so this is the original
text that the Spanish translator wrote
and then I showed you in first
generation translation in the middle how
it'll translate that to English and then
in neural machine translation all the
way on the right hand side and I bolded
the improvement so we can look at a few
of them the first bold word is says
which made drills it's describing the
company where he works and then neural
machine translation is able to change
that word to manufactured which is much
more specific to the context of the
sentence another example is if we look
at where it's describing mrs. Duritz
leaves neck the first generation says
almost twice longer than usual in a
second version it says almost twice as
long as usual which is a slight
improvement and if we look at the bottom
it goes from fence of the fence of the
gardens to garden fence and then the
last example the first generation use
the pronoun
there and then neural machine
translation is able to identify the
correct pronoun who are more
specifically so just a quick example
highlighting some improvements that
neural machine translation brings to the
translation API and on its own the
translation API is pretty
self-explanatory but I wanted to show
you a small demo of a Python script I
wrote of how to combine different api's
together so in this demo it'll take
three types of text input it could take
either raw text audio or an image of
text and then we'll pass it through the
natural language API and then finally
we'll translate it into a few languages
and then we'll translate it back to
English so that you can see the result
so if we could switch back to the demo
looks like up here so I'm going to run
the script Python text aside up high and
it's going to tell me we're going to
send some text to natural language API
it supports English Spanish and Japanese
and I have three options I can either
type my text record a file or send a
photo with text so I'm going to type
some text I'm going to say we are using
the translation API it is awesome and we
got a bunch of data back here so this is
what the JSON response looks like just
for one token I don't want to print the
whole JSON blob here this is just for
the token we this is all the data
returns so it tells us it's a pronoun
and a lot of these part of speech
morphology data is going to be unknown
for English but it relates to other
languages with API supports but it is
able to tell us that it is a plural
token and it is in first person and it
is the nominal subject of the sentence
and we ran some sentiment analysis on it
so it says you seem very happy was an
excited sentence and it tells us the
entities it found that found translation
API and the way the entity analysis
endpoint works is it's able to identify
entities even if they aren't even if
they don't have a Wikipedia URL so
translation API is doesn't but it's
still able to pull this out as an entity
so if we were for example building an
app to make you out customer feedback we
could say okay this feedback is asking
about the translation
and then we could route it to the
appropriate person so now we're going to
translate those texts and let's
translate it into Japanese there we go
so this is the version translated into
Japanese I'm guessing most of us don't
speak Japanese so I translated it back
to English and you can see that it did a
pretty good job so I'm going to run the
script once more and it's then use an
image so if we look over here I've got
just a generic resume image we're going
to pass to the API so I'll clear the
screen and run the text again we're
going to send a photo this time and it
is resume JPEG sending it to the vision
API and the vision API found if we
scroll up all this text in the image
using the new document text extraction
it was able to pull essentially all the
text from that resume there's an example
of what a token returned and it found
all these different entities and now we
can translate it let's translate it to
German a lot of texts vary now this is
the resume translated into German and
then again back to English so just an
example of how you can combine multiple
machine learning ap is to do some cool
text analysis and you can go back to the
slides now so that was the translation
API and the last thing I want to talk
about is the video intelligence API how
many of you saw it at the keynote
yesterday
click most of you and so the video
intelligence API lets you understand
your videos entities at a shot frame or
video level so video level entities will
tell you at a high level what is this
video about and then it'll give you more
granular data on what is happening in
each scene of the video a company that's
using this is Kant mo they're a media
asset management company so a company or
user that has a lot of videos would
upload their videos to Kent MO and
content would help them better
understand those videos search their
library transcode videos this is a quote
from the VP of product development at
Canton
he says thanks to the Google cloud video
intelligence API we've been able to very
quickly process and understand the
content of video down to the individual
frame with an impressively rich taxonomy
so they're using the video API to help
their customers better search their own
video libraries and I'm going to show
you the same demo that you saw in the
keynote but we'll look at a different
video and go into a bit more detail so
if we could switch back to the demo
here's the API and I've got a different
video that I showed in the keynote
earlier this is a video that just shows
you a tour of the Google Paris office
and a little bit of the neighborhood
around it and I'll play the first bit of
it starts out by just showing some
frames and then we'll get into a tour of
the neighborhood around the office and
then we go inside it interviews some
employees I won't play the whole thing
but we can look at some of the labels
that return so if I able to identify
this this amusement ride amusement parks
in the beginning we know there's a bunch
of very short frames in the beginning of
that video it's able to see that it's a
statue if we look at the fruit
annotation it identifies a basket of
fruit in this scene we can scroll down
and look at a couple more labels
landscaping and cuisine see people
getting some food and school here I
think since of school inside there so
you can see we're able to get pretty
granular data on what's happening in
each scene of the video and another
thing the video intelligence API lets us
do is search a large video library right
so for a media publisher
we've got petabytes of video data
sitting in storage buckets it's
otherwise pretty hard to search a large
library of video content you'd have to
manually watch the videos looking for a
particular clip if you want to create
say like a highlight reel of specific
content within your library intelligence
API makes us pretty easy because as you
can see all the data we get back on this
video we get we can get that back on all
the videos in our library
right which makes it pretty easy to
search for a specific entity within our
library so as I showed you in the
keynote
one example is let's say actually first
let me show you the library so we've got
a bunch of videos here as you can see
and let's say we'd like to search for
all our baseball videos we can see what
we get back here and it shows us this
video is almost entirely about baseball
this one has fewer baseball clips and we
can point to all of them specifically
and then in this one we see that moment
from the not playing and try refreshing
the page there we go we see that moment
from the year in search video from last
year when the Cubs won the World Series
I'm from Chicago so I was pretty excited
about that one more search that I showed
you before is we can find all of the
beach clips in our videos so here it's
easy to if we wanted to create a
highlight reel if we were really missing
the beach see all the beach clips in our
videos would be super easy to do this
using the video intelligence API now
since most of you saw this demo in the
keynote I wanted to talk a little bit
more about how I built it so you can go
back to those slides it was built by me
and Alex Wolff if you like the UI you
should give him a shout-out on twitter
at alex wolf he would appreciate it so
we worked on this together and this is
an architecture diagram of how it works
so the video API processing is being
done on the back end and the way it
works is you pass the video intelligence
API Google HOD storage URL of your video
and then it'll run the analysis on that
video so I have a cloud storage bucket
where I'm storing all my videos and I've
got a cloud function listening on that
bucket that cloud function will be
triggered anytime a new file is added to
the bucket it will check if it's a video
if it is it will send it to the video
intelligence API for processing and one
cool thing about the API is you can pass
it the output URL of the URL of a file
you'd like it to write the JSON response
to in Google Cloud storage so I've got a
separate cloud storage bucket or I'm
storing all the video annotation JSON
responses and the API automatically
writes all of my video annotations to
that bucket so the friend in my
application doesn't have to call the
video API directly it's already got all
that metadata in two separate cloud
storage buckets and the front end of the
application is a node.js application
built on Google App Engine that's a
little bit about how the demo works and
this is more granularly what the JSON
response looks like from the video
intelligence API so this is a video of a
tour of the White House and at this
particular point in time it identifies
the label bird's-eye view and it's able
to tell us the start time and end time
in microseconds of where that label
appears in the video and it also returns
a confidence score ranging from zero to
one which will tell us how confident is
the API that it's successfully
identified this as bird's eye view in
this case it is 96% so is pretty
confident that this is a bird's eye view
and then one more snippet of this video
portrait of George Washington and it's
able to successfully identify that this
is a portrait tells us the start time
and end time of where that is in the
video along with a confidence score 83%
so just an example of what the JSON
looks like that you get back from the
video intelligence API that wraps up my
tour of API s and if you all want to
start using them today you can go to the
try it pages and so for each of the API
product pages as I showed you with
vision there's an in-browser demo where
you can try out all the api's directly
in the browser before writing any code
to see if it's right for you and your
application so I definitely recommend
checking that out I'll let you guys take
a picture of that page before I switch
looks like almost everyone got it some
other talks that I recommend that are
related to machine learning bigquery and
cloud machine learning engine was a talk
that was yesterday all the videos from
yesterday have already been posted so if
there's any talks that you wanted to see
that you missed you can go watch them on
YouTube another talk introduction to
video intelligence if you want to see a
deep dive on the video intelligence API
ROM who's a product manager on that is
going to be giving that talk today at 4
p.m. highly recommend checking that talk
out and then if you're more interested
in the side of building and training
your own machine learning model there's
a session tomorrow at 11:20 on the life
cycle of a machine learning model
definitely recommend checking out all
three of these sessions and if you can't
make it you can always watch the videos
on YouTube after the session so thank
you that's all I've got
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]